people need hope especially now what do
you think about
you know crying is bad in in the
business or
never show your weaknesses that's the
most beautiful thing that i can share
with the world could you lead us through
a quick prayer i would love that
today's episode of model monsters is
brought to you by tubebuddy
tubebuddy is your best friend on your
road to youtube success
i use it every day on my channel to get
more views and subscribers
automate the boring tasks and split test
my thumbnails and titles
i've done over 3 800 split tests which
have led to results like taking this
five-year-old video that was getting 250
views a day
and just by changing the thumbnail it
blew up to 15
000 views per day you can get started on
tubebuddy for
free at tubebuddy.com evan
ladies and gentlemen we have the super
talented successful
singer actress entrepreneur
leader of the uh allegiance and now
now author of the new book right here
finding your harmony we got it matching
colors
so happy oh my gosh thank i'm so happy
you have it
i hope you i hope you love it allie
brooke in the house how are you doing
yes i'm doing great you know what's
funny
i actually got one hour of sleep last
night so
i'm i'm here in atlanta filming a movie
and we filmed
very late last night um but despite just
having one hour hours sleep i feel
great i'm happy i'm thankful i'm
thriving
so it's all good and i'm happy to be
talking to you today thank you
you're crushing it for one hour's sleep
um
so trying what why a book so you've done
so many things you
you've you had the the group you had the
solo and you're still doing the solo
stuff you've been on
so many shows why a book
why now tell us the story behind it yes
so i've been through so much in my
my little life even though i'm super
young and
i thought this is a perfect opportunity
to share everything that i've been
through
all the highs and lows the uh the trials
and tribulations the struggles and be
real
bear my truth bear my story and use this
to hopefully help
other young girls who have the same
dreams as me
or who just want to survive another day
you know people need hope especially now
and i've had those moments where i've
had victory mountaintop moments that
feel phenomenal and i've also had those
moments where i've been
crying on the floor like praying to god
god why is this happening god will i
ever
live my life to the fullest my dreams
ever come true and and now living in a
place where i'm so fulfilled
i've overcome so much and i'm i'm truly
living
um my best life right now i just want to
share that with people
share that hope and wisdom and and all
that i can in my heart in my book
i love it now you you talk about your
grandma a lot
in this book um my beautiful grandma
she seemed to be such a source of
inspiration as well as
support for you um and there's so many
pictures of her in here
and you see her kind of you growing up
with her
and obviously you know so she's not here
and she didn't get to see the launch
of your book and everything that's
happened from her kind of looking down
from where she's at right now
what do you think she's saying what do
you think she's thinking cheering you on
with the new book
um well um so i think you're probably
talking about my
my dad's mom and oh my gosh
she would be so proud i lost her at a
very young age
um and she would be just beyond proud
and
you know the other night when my book
came out and it was uh
it was midnight i facetimed my parents
and they were just crying and they were
so overjoyed
and this is something that is not just
for me but it's for my family is
their story too in this book and that's
the most beautiful thing that i can
share with the world is that light that
they deserve
and my dad was just saying he was like
mama she would be so proud and he got
really emotional
and seeing her photos
in this book you know it's very very
special so
she would be proud and she would be
smiling and she would be getting
all of the copies that she could i know
she would
yes oh my beautiful grandma
i love the um how personal you made
everything yeah
yeah yeah there you go pages look how
beautiful she was and that's
me and my brother brandon she's an angel
i love how personally you made
everything and i love how you also put
you know pictures in here but also like
full-on glossy
pictures to really kind of show um you
know to
show your life and show what you've been
through and people may think you haven't
done
you haven't been around that long but
you've been singing since you were nine
years old right it's not like you just
popped up and came out of nowhere
totally and that's a thing that
maybe people don't realize you know
sometimes you see
these artists or entertainers and you're
like oh wow you know it must have been
so easy for them
or their success was very
rapid or overnight or whatever but it is
not
i have been at this for so many years
and have been through it all you know
rejection
and uh even people just being rude
everyone
in the industry from like different
labels to different managers
just just kind of tearing me apart and
saying that hey
you know i don't believe in you you're
not worth anything
blah blah blah and it breaks you but
again
just pushing through that and being
triumphant
coming out on the other side is so it's
so incredible and it's so important to
share because
so many people go through that where
they you know
they they hear so much negativity you
know whether it's
it could be in the workspace or on
social media
but again just being reminded that there
is light
there's a light so that's my purpose
i love it now you said you were shy
growing up is that
are you still shy did you did you break
it is it still in you like how do you
no i am not shy well you know it's funny
because now
um and i really honestly do attribute
this to one of my heroes
selena when i was a young girl um you
know like you said i was super shy
but watching her her personality and her
movie
um and i i do talk about it in the book
she inspired me to uh
be my best self and to come out of my
shell
and so i feel like i i get so much of my
inspiration from her
but um now i'm totally the opposite i'm
not shy i love talking to everybody
in fact i thrive off of conversations
and meeting my fans in person
and it's such a bummer that i can't do
that you know we're planning this whole
book tour and all but it's okay
i actually have a virtual book tour
tonight and of course we have technology
now which is awesome
but um you know what's funny though i
will admit
when it comes to me meeting like certain
celebrities
i get i actually get like starstruck and
i kind of just
close off and i become shy who's uh
the ultimate on your list that you still
want to connect with and and say hi to
oh oh my gosh there's so many
um well i talk about carrie underwood
and this
and how she helped to bring me out of
such a low place
in my life and how her her music
kind of just brought so much life into
me in light
um so to be able to meet her and just to
say what her music
means to me um she's such an inspiration
for many years that would be incredible
also
dolly parton i love dolly parton so much
wow okay awesome um
there's so many different different
artists out there who i love
but those are a few is that part of your
ambition to have
like if you think about the longevity
how long is dolly parton
being in the business and still going
like is that
is that part of the inspirations like i
want to be i look at her and say when
when i'm you know maybe that old but in
a nice way
i would still love to be doing the work
right to still be
contributing i don't sing but i make
videos is that part of why you love her
oh my gosh yes and what i love about
she's just like an angel
what i love about her is that she is
just such a pure-hearted
loving beautiful soul um
and you know in this business that's
sometimes not celebrated i mean i've
been told before that oh you're too nice
or oh you gotta like be
someone else you know you gotta be a
little more rude or
whatever crazy things and it's like no
it's possible and for me it's all about
longevity you know and
and that's why i i do what i do i have
passions in so many areas
obviously writing obviously music now
acting
and um just entertaining in general and
it's about
not just the next year or two it's about
the next 20 years 30 years so that's
definitely
what i um what i aspire to be like one
day and also just to be known not for
any drama or anything like that but just
to be known for the music and
hopefully the heart so
i love it i love it so i mean the book
here it is finding your harmony you guys
can
can pick it up on youtube we'll link it
up in the description
what's the what's the most i'm sure
there's so many stories that came out of
this obviously you're sharing your story
but the reaction that's that's come out
what's the story that fuels you up the
most are you most grateful for
or whether it's fan or family that's
come from the launch of the book
just to hear the feedback of how
how people really saw my heart in this
and how
it inspired them and their faith and
their walk
and them to not give up hope is
incredible that is the purpose of this
book
and then also saying my fans are now
they they haven't read it
yet but they're getting into it and on
certain
chapters and they're so moved and
i see their comments right now and
they're uh
they're crying with me they're relating
um
to my stories and they're hopefully
gonna see
that hey i went through everything that
you are going through
it may be in a different sphere but it's
still all the same
pain is the same rejection is the same
you know online bullying is the same
and for me i give so many tools and tips
in the book on how to overcome that how
to survive it
and how to just get through life so um
just hearing so far that it's already
touched people and
and also they just love my parents
and they get that that recognition
that there i saw coming i think
yesterday saying like oh my gosh
i'm just beginning your book and your
parents i just want to hug them
it's incredible it's the best feeling
they deserve the world
talk about showing emotion because you
wear your heart on your sleeve
you're so you know open in sharing
i mean the big highs but also the the
devastating
lows and and the crushes and and you
know you can feel
the crying kind of with you through some
of the section of the book
what do you think about you know crying
is bad in
in the business or never show your
weaknesses
uh like that whole line of thinking what
would you say to them
i think certain mottos work first
work for certain people um for me
uh you know this business look
people handle it differently you know
what i mean and like
i remember oh my gosh there was a point
where
i didn't even put this in the book but
one example we were at an award show
and last minute i think uh
there was a huge change and uh
i was being told um
because i think it had to do something
with wardrobe or something
and there was all this this pressure on
me and
and all of these like just crazy um
i don't want to say accusations at all
but basically
i was trying to stand up for myself and
say hey like i'm not comfortable with
this it's
not and then this this person tells me
the means means like
you're not a woman stop crying you need
to to
not show emotion you need to be a leader
and blah blah blah and i'm like
over here right before it's performed
crying my eyes out and there's
there's a she was uh like an assistant
um or day to day manager excuse me who
witnessed this and she was like
ally don't you dare listen to what that
woman said
you are amazing i don't know how you
just took that right now you took that
way better than i would
um don't let her words affect you and i
just felt like
wow like i felt so just just shattered
you know and embarrassed humiliated and
your mind's just
to second guessing yourself um
you know i've i feel like because of
that and also
seeing in the guitar made days like oh
my gosh
ally's like crying or whatever um like
you said i wear my heart in my sleep
i'm i'm emotional but not in like a
uh extreme way i i feel like it's more
of
i just feel things deeply like i'm an
empath i'm a deep feeler i say that in
my book
and so when things hurt you know it
really
tears up my heart and when things are
incredible i mean it just feels like i'm
touching the sky
um but anyways with that thinking look
it works for a lot of different people
yes i feel like i've definitely worked
on
kind of being a little bit more stronger
and and honing in my emotions
but i think you know especially as women
like we want to
you know cry because something
devastating happened or or
were overwhelmed or whatever i mean
that's that's fine you should feel
safe you know what i mean i mean
obviously handling that in the correct
way and managing your emotions in a
healthy manner
but um yeah i just feel like
each of their own i guess does that make
sense
yeah i mean i loved it i thought it was
super refreshing um
i get a lot of entrepreneur and kind of
business books
and everybody's kind of all got the
answers and
they're all figured out and you're
perfect and you're trying to learn from
this person and here you are with this
like super raw
authentic and still giving advice and
coaching like hey here are the things
that help me
but not pretending to have it all
figured out
exactly that you're perfect yeah exactly
and just owning that and
saying hey here's my walk and here's my
advice what helped me
and we're doing it together that's what
i love you know is that we're on this
journey
together i love it now you talk about
being
a people pleaser and and how that kind
of
hurt you you know in getting started in
the business is that still
there is does that go away is it just
evolve like
where are you at with that now you know
what's crazy i feel like again i learned
so many lessons in fifth harmony
and now i'm just so different like
i think there always will be a people
pleaser inside of me as far as just i
don't want to offend
anyone i don't want to upset anyone but
i've gotten so much
better at being like no i'm not going to
tolerate this
no i'm not going to do this and yes
i want to do this i'm comfortable
let's try to make that happen um kind of
just owning myself
my power you know as a woman as an
artist as an entertainer
and my value and my worth and for the
first time
feeling like that in my life it's it is
crazy it is
such a rewarding feeling and uh you know
again just going from
being to stomped all over for so many
years in this business
just kind of bowing my head saying yes
everything but inside
not being fulfilled not being treated
with respect not
being uh um not being shown my value
you know my worth now i'm at a place
where i'm owning that
you know and it's so awesome and i want
to encourage
all the women out there to own that and
to not be afraid
and you know it's not easy
sometimes especially when you know
you're met with like different opinions
or opposition but
just standing strong in your truth and
and who you are and what you want is
incredible and
and we have the power to do that and be
that so pulling on that threat you know
you talk about
your worth when especially when you're
first getting started
and you want to believe in your worth
but
it's shaky you know it's like you kind
of don't believe in your worth and you
don't know if you're going to make it
and then you get voices around you
saying
you suck you're never going to make it
you're too you know xyz
from the industry and then you get the
fans saying you you know all of these
things
how do you how do you keep going
how do you maintain that worth to say no
i
am worthy i can't do this like what did
you do
well number one as you'll see in in my
book is just
my faith relying on like
what god says about me and relying on
that truth and my family
and my friends who know me um
having them be there for me giving me
advice
lift me up remind me of my value
and my worth and to stand strong in that
has really helped me also therapy
therapy is really great if you can get
it
um it's awesome and if you can't get
therapy
there are so many videos out there to
help you and so many different
interviews that you can check out
but um you know it helps just working on
yourself
um identifying certain issues even
traumas that maybe you have like
tucked away or you're just trying to
block out
it's so empowering but all those things
really helped me
to to navigate those feelings and those
challenges and
i also feel like i'm at a point in my
life
um where now i'm just like
no like i know who i am and i'm i'm
gonna
believe that and value it and on those
days where i feel
you know not the best then i turn to you
know my friends
therapists parents fans
fans are awesome they they always um
make me smile you know but that's my
advice
is there a a certain prayer you would
say
when you're really struggling or a
conversation you would have
um um well kind of just whatever
is happening like for example if um
if i i don't know was like
okay so on after the x factor when my
audition aired
just kind of praying like god please
comfort me
and also kind of saying like why did you
let this happen
and like being real and being honest
with my feelings
but also just saying like please help me
through this situation help me to see
that there is
a light out there and that there is hope
and
help me to not give up um just being so
honest
of what i want to see in the end goal
and the resolution that's what
what helps me and then also devotions
are awesome
because they remind me of of the truth
of who i am and who we're
we're called to be as like humans in in
our value and our worth when the world's
trying to take that away from you
so that always really helps too
could you lead us through a quick prayer
like i'm just wondering if there's
somebody
i would love that like just put yourself
in issues of uh
someone like you from like eight years
ago who's struggling
who the world's against her and
and maybe she can come and rewind and
watch this part of the video
oh wow and it's like a joint prayer
together well i'd be honored
okay okay thank you so much
okay dear god
thank you so much for this this moment
thank you so much for
this opportunity to be here and to talk
about my story and my stories your story
and how you've just changed my life um i
pray right now for anybody who is
struggling
feeling alone feeling hopeless feeling
like
they're at a roadblock in their life
whether it's with a relationship or
friendship
or or their career i just pray that you
just
you just breathe life into them and hope
into them lord
even if they're feeling completely
hopeless please lord
let there be that voice inside of them
let your your
your voice be there to say
you will get through this to say i'm
with you to say
you are not alone to say that the best
is yet to come
lord please father god instill that in
someone's heart
i know these times are crazy a lot of
people are feeling alone
and isolated but please let them know
that they're not alone
you're with them you're watching them
even when sometimes life seems
crazy life seems impossible seems like
you're not gonna make it lord
you say that you're gonna make it
and i pray god that that by me
opening up about those times where i
felt
angry and sad and scared and hopeless
that that will
shine a light to someone who who needs
to hear the words that
you can overcome any situation
for me it was cancer in my family it was
me not knowing that reconciliation would
ever come
it was me not knowing that i would ever
be able to make my music again
and so much more please lord just bless
that person put
infuse joy in their hearts and use light
and um something beautiful inside them
to not give up to not be afraid
to have confidence and a peace that
transcends all understanding we just
pray for that person
light love and hope and your wonderful
name
thank you so much jesus
amen that was great wow
there's some i mean there's some good
lyrics there for you there for your next
song that was
there's some fire in there that was
awesome oh my gosh thank you that was
great
thank you that was all him so i i hope
it helps somebody i really do
thank you i've never done that before
like i don't think ever on like a live
or interview or anything so
thank you you know what it was channeled
it was channeled
i haven't done that either so we made it
happen yes
cool so the book everybody here it is
finding your harmony ali brook go check
it out
the link will put in the description on
youtube any any final words ally you
want to share with
your live audience here my live audience
and the youtube audience too
thank you guys for watching again i hope
that uh
you can just see that
the impossible is possible that
god can move mountains and what um
the doors that man can shut he can
reopen
sorry and i'm great just like so much
love to you um
yes and just thank you again thank you
so much for this
this opportunity amazing thank you for
joining us i hope you get a little bit
of sleep before going on your movie set
i definitely will thank you so much this
was
so incredible appreciate you thank you
ali
thank you cheers if you want to change
your life for the next 30 days for free
check the link right here below me
or if you want to see the one-on-one i
did with lisa bill you check the video
right there next to me
i think you'll enjoy them continue to
believe and i'll see you there